for seven years canadian forces trained
thousands of ukrainian troops a level of
trust and interoperability has been
established that puts this country on
ukraine's list of potential security
guarantors we've been in close contact
with our ukrainian counterparts since
the beginning of this crisis the foreign
affairs minister wouldn't address it but
could a role emerge as negotiators for
ukraine and russia create some daylight
on ceasefire talks
the aim says this ukrainian presidential
advisor is to receive security
guarantees to stop the conflict one
defense expert sees a possible role for
canada as a peacekeeping nation with
relationships among many countries
historically this aligns with canada's
contributions it is entirely conceivable
that canada
will be looking to leverage
those relationships
to play a possible role as
as an honest broker and a security
grunter among the possible security
guarantor nations named by ukraine
turkey and israel which have maintained
relations with russia poland the nation
that has absorbed the most ukrainian
refugees and canada this country is
currently in latvia where canadian
forces lead a nato mission and canada's
military was on the ground until
recently in ukraine with operation
unifier a relationship that is
long-standing and deep
as recently as eight weeks ago canada's
defense minister was in kiev shortly
before canadian military trainers pulled
out of ukraine we've trained over
30 000 ukrainian forces and they're
showing themselves proving their medal
in the battlefield so we bring with us
all kinds of
interoperability skills
and
alliance links that can be used by
ukraine to increase the security a
ceasefire is not at hand but a security
force would have to be ready to go
quickly canada has a significant
experience with ukrainian bureaucracy
and in particular with the ukrainian
defense establishment if and when a
request comes for canada to play a role
in ukraine's future security one source
in ottawa told global news the
government will consider it eric
sorenson global news toronto